[Aplausos]
[Música]
y
la guerra fría terminó hace ya mucho
pero que mucho tiempo o al menos eso es
lo que nos quieren contar porque en la
vieja europa hay una región donde la
sombra de moscú sigue muy pero que muy
presente casi tanto como para decir que
en cierto modo la guerra fría sigue viva
tres décadas después de la extinción de
la unión soviética y es precisamente en
este lugar donde nos encontramos
queridos amigos amigas muy pero que muy
al norte y encajadas entre europa
central y escandinavia por el lado amigo
y por rusia y bielorrusia por el lado
hostil se encuentran los tres países
bálticos estonia letonia y lituania
[Música]
los tres países bálticos formaron parte
de la mismísima unión soviética hasta su
desintegración en 1991 es decir estonia
letonia y lituania no formaron estados
satélites como polonia hungría sino
parte misma de la gran potencia
comunista pero sobre todo la cuestión
que nos atañe es que los bálticos fueron
y los siguen siendo un punto clave para
moscú un acceso privilegiado al mar
báltico un mar que los conecta
directamente con el motor de europa a
alemania además las tres repúblicas se
han convertido en una de las regiones
más prósperas de toda europa
por este y otros motivos son muchos los
expertos en temática militar que
consideran que estas regiones en
potencia un auténtico polvorín un centro
de profundas tensiones políticas y
militares sobre todo militares
lituania dice que dos aviones militares
rusos han violado su espacio aéreo
aviones de la otan detectaron un navío
militar ruso cerca de la frontera letona
la historia dice que aviones rusos
violaron su espacio aéreo otra vez tal y
como podéis ver los países bálticos una
franja relativamente pequeña de 175 mil
kilómetros cuadrados equivalentes al
tamaño de un país como uruguay se han
convertido en todo un quebradero de
cabeza para la otan
[Música]
y
contrarrestar la amenaza rusa proteger
las fronteras y limitar la influencia
que moscú tiene son los objetivos la
pregunta es cómo quiere lograrlo la otan
porque se han convertido las tres
repúblicas bálticas en uno de los
mayores focos de interés de las
instituciones occidentales cuáles son
sus principales debilidades y cuáles las
principales fortalezas y quizás amigos
la pregunta más importante de todas
podría la otan repeler una invasión rusa
al estilo ucraniano pues bien en este
vídeo y desde aquí y desde las
repúblicas bálticas vamos a responder a
estas y otras muchas preguntas así que
arranquemos
[Música]
un país dos sociedades
démosle una vuelta cuál fue realmente la
clave que sobre cualquier otra explica
el éxito de la intervención rusa en
ucrania
seguro que muchos estáis pensando en las
tropas que rusia puso sobre el terreno
aunque fueran sin bandera y en su mayor
preparación y equipamiento sin embargo
darle otra vuelta realmente ha sido
posible el éxito ruso si no hubiera sido
por la existencia de grandes bolsas de
población rusa pues bien sabéis que como
os quedáis si os digo que este mismo
ingrediente exactamente este mismo
ingrediente se encuentra también aquí en
estonia y en el resto de las repúblicas
bálticas fijaos
lituania se calcula que a día de hoy el
48 por ciento de la población del país
es de etnia rusa y si puede que esta
cifra nos parezca particularmente alta
pero es que lituania es precisamente la
excepción porque el porcentaje de
población rusa en estonia se sitúa en
torno al 24% y en letonia aún más un
25,2 por ciento por
[Música]
supuesto el que haya más o menos
población rusa en un determinado lugar
no es algo necesariamente negativo el
problema amigos surge cuando su
situación social ilegal favorece su
exclusión y separación y ese es
precisamente el caso
fijaos en este barrio donde nos
encontramos las mamás este es un barrio
de mayoría rusa donde apenas uno de cada
cuatro habitantes son de origen
culturalmente estonio aquí amigos la
comunidad rusa es predominante hablamos
de más de 80 mil habitantes que
mantienen fuertes vínculos de comunidad
entre sí y que viven en un auténtico
museo al aire libre de la época
soviética algo así como una rusia dentro
de estonia este es el principal núcleo
ruso en una ciudad está allí en donde
más del 35% de la población es
precisamente rusa hablamos de una
población
y esto es lo importante que tiene
características propias muy pero que muy
marcadas fijaos
[Música]
en los tres países las zonas con menor
renta son precisamente aquellas donde
más porcentaje de rusos viven y ojo
porque no hablamos de una diferencia
pequeña el nivel de renta puede ser un
40 e incluso un 50% más bajo que el de
las zonas más ricas y prósperas
[Música]
pero eso eso no es todo la población
rusa en los países bálticos funciona en
la práctica como una especie de segunda
sociedad o mejor dicho de sociedad de
segundo orden y aunque de su situación
si ha mejorado durante los últimos años
las diferencias siguen siendo siderales
[Música]
aquí en estonia por ejemplo el país
báltico donde quizás más dificultades ha
tenido la asimilación de la población
rusa todavía a día de hoy hay atentos
unas 70.000 personas étnicamente rusas
que son literalmente apátridas que se lo
habéis escuchado bien unas 70.000
personas en torno al 6% de toda la
población del país que no tienen
ciudadanía ni pasaporte ni derecho a
voto de las elecciones nacionales y
tampoco es que sean ciudadanos rusos
simplemente hablamos de 70.000 personas
que no son ciudadanos de ningún país sin
ir más lejos aquí en este barrio en las
namás podemos encontrar muchos ejemplos
de personas que formalmente no
pertenecen a ningún país y si ya sé lo
que estáis pensando cómo demonios puede
ser esto posible
[Música]
pues veréis el origen de esta
rocambolesca situación se sitúa en 1991
cuando el gobierno estonio tomó una
decisión firme conceder la ciudadanía
exclusivamente a todas aquellas personas
que fueran ciudadanos antes de la
ocupación soviética de 1940 así como
lógicamente a sus descendientes al resto
a los rusos que habían llegado durante
la ocupación soviética nada de nada y
ojo porque algo muy similar ocurrió en
letonia un país donde cerca del 7% de la
población se encuentra en esta misma
situación hablamos en este caso de más
de 130.000 apátridas pues bien tal y
como os podéis imaginar esta situación
no sólo alimenta la exclusión la
segregación racial y la falta de
oportunidades de este colectivo de
población rusa sino que también hay en
el camino para que las estrategias de
desinformación y matriculación
auspiciadas por el kremlin sean
efectivas y sabéis que en moscú son
perfectamente conscientes de ello
precisamente por eso el gobierno ruso
lleva años intentando alimentar un
sentimiento de confrontación y
construcción nacional entre esta
población ahora bien hasta donde han
llegado las autoridades rusas y la
pregunta más importante de todas que
potencial tienen realmente este tipo de
estrategias atentos
la guerra híbrida
[Música]
de dónde viene por qué tanto interés por
parte de rusia hacia los países bálticos
es acaso una cuestión de mero resquemor
histórico es quizás para frenar la
influencia de la unión europea o se
trata de una cuestión de cni o
imperialismo pues todo ello y nada al
mismo tiempo sobre el papel amigos el
argumento que esgrime rusia es la idea
del mundo ruso ahora bien que es
exactamente eso del mundo ruso pues
veréis para vladimir putin cuando se
habla de rusia y del pueblo ruso no se
habla exclusivamente de los rusos que
viven en la actual rusia sino del
conjunto de rusos que hay designados por
todo el mundo y especialmente en el
entorno ex soviético es por así decirlo
una definición ampliada de las
responsabilidades políticas del kremlin
[Música]
de esta forma la estrategia de los
gobiernos de putin pasa por materializar
este concepto del mundo ruso así el
gobierno quiere vincular a la mayor
cantidad posible de minorías de habla
rusa con la madre patria porque pues
porque consideran que estas minorías
rusas son un medio político fundamental
para extender la influencia del país de
hecho tanto es así que en guerras
pasadas moscú ya aludió como argumento
principal a la hora de intervenir la
idea de proteger a sus compatriotas
hablamos por ejemplo de la guerra de
georgia o de las intervenciones
militares en crimea y el donbass
ucraniano
ahora bien estamos en los bálticos y la
pregunta que podemos hacernos es qué
significa todo esto como pretende el
gobierno ruso ejercer aquí su influencia
pues queridos amigos amigas la respuesta
es la guerra híbrida
la guerra híbrida es un tipo de
conflicto no convencional en el que se
busca desgastar al enemigo combinando
por ejemplo medios políticos económicos
e informáticos medios siempre de corte
no estrictamente militar esto se logra
por ejemplo mediante campañas de
desinformación ataques cibernéticos
chantajes con el suministro de energía
interfiriendo en procesos electorales o
apoyando y formando a grupos radicales e
insurgentes todas estas tácticas tienen
un impacto enorme en la seguridad de un
país y también en la funcionalidad e
incluso la legitimidad de sus
instituciones
[Música]
y si casi todas estas prácticas son las
que rusia aplica contra los bálticos
pero queréis algunos ejemplos concretos
pues fijaos informe a que rusos se
aprovechan de la infraestructura lituana
presuntos piratas informáticos apoyados
por rusia apuntan a las redes de energía
del báltico y no pensáis ni por un
segundo que los ataques informáticos son
los únicos ejemplos que podemos poner
sobre la mesa podemos encontrar muchos
muchísimos más
sin ir más lejos se sabe que el gobierno
ruso final un secreto un grupo de webs
de noticias llamadas values que eran en
apariencia independientes la intención
era poder difundir historias y noticias
dictadas directamente por el premio todo
con un objetivo muy claro hacer girar
los bálticos desde una cosmovisión pro
occidental a otra mucho más pro rusa y
para ello amigos el gobierno ruso sabe y
aún más importante que incluir en el
estamento político puede ser hacerlo
directamente en la calle en la propia
gente de ahí que sea tan importante
llevar a cabo campañas de desinformación
fake news denuncias sobre derechos
humanos captación de datos o amenazas
políticas y económicas pero un momento
porque éstas tampoco son las únicas
herramientas de guerra híbrida que rusia
emplea en esta región de europa hay otra
aún más preocupante lo que podríamos
denominar como la estrategia de la
tensión constante
amigos la presencia militar rusa en esta
región es enorme hablamos de una
concentración de equipos y tropas de tal
calibre que muchos expertos militares
dudan de que realmente la otan pudiera
hacer algo para frenar una hipotética
invasión rusa algo más por supuesto que
el poder de disuasión de la propia otan
pero de que amenaza estamos hablando
exactamente como es la amenaza militar
rusa a la que se pueden estar
enfrentando estos tres países bálticos
estonia letonia y lituania
pues bien atentos
[Música]
talón de aquiles de la otan
bienvenidos a la base de misiles
nucleares soviéticos de blocks team
situada en el oeste lituano muy cerca
del mar báltico fue la primera base
subterránea de ataque nuclear de toda la
unión soviética este amigo será uno de
los lugares con los que el ejército rojo
contaba para desplegar su poder
destructivo durante años este fue un
punto caliente en la confrontación entre
el este y el oeste y hoy hoy refleja
como pocos el triunfo del bloque
occidental una vez parte fundamental del
mismísimo sistema de disuasión nuclear
de la unión soviética hoy es una
instalación abierta al público en un
país miembro pleno de la organización
del tratado del atlántico norte la otan
amigos durante décadas la otan ha sido y
sigue siendo una herramienta clave un
contrapeso en el sistema de poder
mundial democracia libertad frente
autocracias liberticidas esto es cierto
pero también lo es que esta organización
tiene debilidades puntos flacos y
algunos de ellos los podemos encontrar
precisamente aquí
actualmente los tres países bálticos
cuentan con bases y tropas desplegadas
de la otan para defender por tierra mar
y aire las fronteras que separan el
bloque occidental de rusia a día de hoy
hablamos de más de 35.000 soldados
teniendo en cuenta tanto las tropas
nacionales de estos tres países como a
las unidades de apoyo desplegadas por
países como eeuu reino unido a alemania
o canadá
claro que ante un hipotético conflicto
de los bálticos rusia no sólo gana el
número también puede ganar en medios
capacidades y geoestrategia echemos un
vistazo por ejemplo al caso de lituania
este punto que estáis viendo es el
corredor de suv aunque una franja de
unos 90 kilómetros que conecta lituania
con polonia y el resto de los países de
la otan en europa central el problema
amigos está en que lo que rodea ese
corredor es territorio hostil por el
este bielorrusia y por el oeste
kaliningrado es decir la propia madre
rusia por cierto sobre de kaliningrado
hicimos hace no mucho tiempo un vídeo
que os puede ayudar a comprender el
contexto general de la guerra fría
báltica os dejo el enlace por aquí abajo
en la descripción pero no nos desviemos
[Música]
la cuestión es la enorme facilidad con
la que he llegado el momento rusia
podría aislar a los tres países bálticos
bastaría simplemente con ocupar este
corredor o atacarlo para impedir el paso
es todo un embudo para las fuerzas de la
otan y ojo porque no hablamos
necesariamente de una ocupación ni un
ataque formal los expertos militares
apuntan también a una posible
movilización de una fuerza aparentemente
irregular parecida a las que rusia
utilizó para ocupar crimea o
desestabilizar el donbass de hecho una
intervención de este tipo es quizás lo
que más preocupa a los tres países
bálticos no es sólo en este corredor
sino sobre todo en sus partes del
territorio con mayoría de población rusa
pero ojo porque este no es el único
punto débil de la otan en los
alrededores de kaliningrado el ejército
ruso tiene desplegado un sistema militar
avanzado que ha creado una capacidad
adosada de anti acceso denegación de
áreas
hablamos de un complejo sistema que
permite impedir el movimiento a fuerzas
adversarias por tierra mar y aire tanto
en kaliningrado como en zonas limítrofes
esto se logra gracias a una red de
sistemas de defensa aérea superpuestos
incluyendo desde 2019 el sistema
antiaéreo s400 ruso artillería de largo
alcance misiles balísticos
convencionales y nucleares incluidos 12
misiles iskander de doble uso y misiles
de crucero también hay armas anti buque
y anti submarinas sistemas de guerra
electrónica y obviamente numerosos
aviones de combate cazas y tanques entre
otros muchos equipos y no olvidemos a la
flota del báltico que está estacionada
aquí para evitar que la otan pueda
utilizar sus flotas de la zona en su
contra de esta forma rusia busca no sólo
perpetuar su dominio sobre kaliningrado
y proteger su único puerto báltico que
no se llevan todo el año sino también
mantener a raya a los tres países
bálticos y con ello a toda la otan
el problema de este tipo de pulsos y
carreras armamentísticas es que por un
error por una mala interpretación o un
despiste en un momento determinado las
cosas pueden escaparse de control ese es
el riesgo
letonia advierte del riesgo de un
incidente entre la otan y rusia tenemos
una crisis fronteriza tenemos un
importante ejercicio militar en las
fronteras de los países de la otan
también ha aumentado la presencia por
nuestro lado el lado lituano el lado
estonio el lado polaco de los guardias
fronterizos y las formaciones militares
por supuesto esto está aumentando la
posibilidad de incidentes édgar rinkeby
ex ministro de relaciones exteriores de
letonia por supuesto el argumento que
esgrime rusia para mantener un enorme
despliegue en la zona es que bajo su
punto de vista es la otan quien tiene
rodeada la región mientras que para la
organización del tratado del atlántico
norte sin embargo que el inem grado es
una especie de fortaleza militar rusa
dentro del territorio del bloque pero
fijaos en este mapa en el podéis ver la
enorme concentración de medios militares
que rusia ha dispuesto en toda su
frontera occidental por ejemplo en eskup
a tan sólo 32 km de la frontera con
estonia rusia tiene desplegada una
división de asalto aéreo y una brigada
de las fuerzas especiales rusas los navy
seals de fútil
sin contar ni siquiera con las fuerzas
de kaliningrado muchos expertos
militares apuntan a que rusia goza de
una importante superioridad operativa en
la zona la propia otan calcula que los
rusos serían capaces de desplegar
rápidamente entre 50.000 y 60.000
soldados en apenas unos pocos días
además la amenaza para los países
bálticos podría llegar desde direcciones
diferentes lo que dificulta aún más la
defensa de la zona
pero vale evidentemente hoy por hoy la
posibilidad de un conflicto armado es
razonablemente pequeña y desde luego no
podemos olvidar el poder disuasorio que
tiene la propia otra pero amigos los
errores existen y no solo tenemos que
pensar en un incidente fortuito el
importante peso que tiene la comunidad
rusa en estonia y letonia su escasa
integración en la vida civil y política
y su relativa mala situación económica
podrían favorecer movimientos de choque
y rebelión o protesta que podrían llegar
a causar importantes daños a la
estabilidad de los tres países bálticos
esa es la auténtica amenaza y en ella el
juego de la guerra híbrida y la tensión
constante desplegado por rusia es la
mayor de las bajas
[Música]
hoy los tipos de guerra han cambiado y
sitios como este ya han pasado a la
historia pero eso no quiere decir amigos
que no existan amenazas dicho esto ha
llegado hasta aquí turno para ti crees
que la otan tiene que incrementar su
despliegue en su frontera oriental como
crees que deberían los países
occidentales enfrentarse a una acción de
guerra y unidad masiva en los bálticos
como la que ya se produjo en ucrania de
qué forma pueden acortarse los riesgos
déjanos tu opinión por aquí abajo en los
comentarios y por cierto si te gusta lo
que hacemos ahora puedes formar parte de
este proyecto y ayudar a que siga
creciendo unirte a nuestra comunidad de
patria una vez más muchas gracias por
estar ahí un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]